Speaker 1: Hey, here is a bit of this is sort
of like it's bad news in the sense of we want
presidents being briefed on on intelligence
matters. But in a way it's almost like good news.
And I'm going to explain why. In a second, there's
a new report that after the riots of January 6th,
at which point Donald Trump had two weeks left
as president, he never got another intelligence
briefing. After that, he just started rejecting
the intelligence briefings. This is very, very
interesting. The report from The Daily Beast is
that after a holiday break where he didn't receive
a classified intel briefing, Trump was supposed
to get one on January six. That's the day he
incited the riots. And it didn't happen, and then
he didn't get one for the rest of his presidency,
and he hasn't gotten one since. Remember, former
presidents are entitled to get those briefings.
There was this idea that maybe Joe Biden would
block Trump from getting future briefings, but as
far as we know, it has not been done that unusual
stretch where the sitting president didn't receive
a regular classified briefing, as recounted in the
latest version of the book published and regularly
revised by the CIA, which describes how spies
update presidents on national security matters.
The situation in the waning days of Trump's
presidency was so uncommon it actually caused
concern among some administration officials that
Trump was losing touch with reality as he was
getting unhinged advice on domestic issues from
Justice Department attorneys and outside counsel
that openly advocated rejecting election results.
One source said. The Daily Beast. There was
no certainty that he was getting objective,
unbiased info in any other way. You couldn't
trust that anybody around him was able to get
that information to him in that period of time.
Unlike past presidents who would read their
daily intelligence report and get briefed,
Trump regularly refused to read the
text, demanded killer pictures and
preferred to get updated in person by his daily
briefer. It all came to a halt in late 2020,
and we talked a little bit about that yesterday.
Now I want to be really upfront with you guys.
The country may have been better off by
Donald Trump not getting those briefings
after that period of time. If he was
getting the briefings at that point
when he was completely triggered, unhinged off
the rails, trying to steal back the election,
who knows what he might have done with the
information from the briefings? Who knows
where he might have blabbed about information
from the briefings? And this is so insane. But
in a weird way, it's almost slightly reassuring
that Trump wasn't being briefed at the time. Now
it's important to remember, as the article sort
of mentions, he wasn't really getting much in the
way of briefings to begin with for the majority
of his presidency. He wasn't reading them former
President Obama Bush. They would get a multi-page
briefing, mostly text, and they would read it.
And then they might have follow up questions for
an in-person briefing. Trump wasn't reading it.
He had the briefing reduced to a single
page and that one page by multiple reports
half the page was some kind of a picture, chart
or graph. And then there were like two to three
bullet points. That's what it was being reduced
to. And then he just wanted people to talk to him,
sometimes with TV's on in the background, so he
couldn't sit through them. But it's not obvious
to me that it's bad. Listen, it's bad that you
have a president who can't sit through and read
something. It's bad that you have a president
that doesn't care to be briefed. That's all bad,
given that it was Trump specifically. And given
that even in the Oval Office, he spilled secrets
from an ally to a Russian spy recruiter to, I
guess, look, alpha in his mind. Given Trump's
emotional state in those last two weeks of the
presidency, I'm almost reassured by the fact that
he was not taking those daily briefings. Let
me know your thoughts, but it is a very, very
bizarre thing that hopefully will never happen
again. But I fear, unfortunately, that it will